There are two ways you can figure out what this z-critical value is. One is to
look at the z table and find the value for which 2.5% is less than that. So, if
we look for 0.025, or 2.5%, we see that it's here at negative 1.96. So, that
means that this z-critical value is negative1.96 because 2.5% is less than
that. And since this distribution is symmetrical, that means that this
z-critical value would be positive 1.96. Another thing you could have done is
noted that if 2.5% is up here in the blue region, then 97.5% is below the
z-critical value. Then, you could have looked for 0.975 in the z-table and then
you would get positive 1.96. This is called the two tailed test. When we split
the alpha level in half, we see that its two tailed. And then our z-critical
values become both the positive and negative of the same number.